yes the title of the video is correct
this is a game called chair [ __ ]
simulator whether you think that's just
to play on words or it's a euphemism or
it's something that's gonna be
misleading and turn out to be something
else I don't think that's what this game
is the Internet is a wonderful place
where people can share ideas and there's
something for everybody
apparently this is one of those things
for not everybody but somebody so when I
go into this I don't think that there's
going to be any subtlety to it I don't
think that there's gonna be any hidden
meaning behind it I'm pretty sure this
is going to be straight-up chair [ __ ]
I can't honestly say I want to [ __ ] a
chair but I'm here I paid money for this
game I paid money for this game so I
might as well say this but I don't like
making this declaration I'm not saying
this to the world
that I want to [ __ ] a chair it's not
necessarily true oh also by the way if
it wasn't obvious this is not going to
be family-friendly look guys we're in
this together
you clicked on this video cuz you were
curious I got this game because I was
curious we're all in this together it
doesn't mean anything about us oh we're
in this together now we've made a pact
we've made an agreement and we're gonna
go into this with both eyes open and
heart full of acceptance of what this
could possibly be I'm not stalling I
might be stalling but we're gonna go
into this but you're making a commitment
to me that you're on this journey with
me
because once we go in you cannot back
out no matter what happens no matter
what we see in there no matter what you
see me do and it's a judgment-free zone
yes sure I wanna [ __ ] a chair why not
saxophone hoop hey kids I am [ __ ]
chairs over here do you like this music
drop kick me Jesus through the goal
posts of life likes human foods such as
meat pudding or meat pudding Backstreet
Boys reunion tours hats like supplying
lotion to tacos water Jodorowsky's sonic
I don't know who Jodorowsky's
act 1 the introduction so many ways a
tenement like this I don't like the
onliest 3 fingers I don't the way like
the way his toes curl up I don't like
how knobbly his knees are I don't like
his legs in general I don't like that he
looks like the punching bag from Super
Smash Brothers I don't like his teeth I
don't like his eyes I don't like his
rotund body I don't like the crease in
the back of his neck if that is his neck
I don't like that I don't know where his
neck is and if that is his neck I don't
like that his neck is below his arms I
also don't like that it has a chin is
that his chin is that his gut is that
just the fold in his chest I don't like
the way he's biting the air I don't like
the way he's bouncing back and forth
those are just some of the many ways
that I don't like this also the toilet
is a problem I was told I was I guess it
it if a chair is defined as something
you sit upon I'm assuming that this is
that achievement oh no what did I just
see okay I don't know what act to look
if this is a standard three act
structure then we got a little bit of a
problem oh my god
apparently I'm running out of [ __ ] do I
hit the Pat was that ice person hit the
power act 2/3 the climate and I don't
like this well I guess there's nothing
implicitly wrong no everything's wrong I
can't justify the situation at all so I
might as well go in go in elbow-deep if
there's really what we're gonna be doing
[Applause]
well what oh my goodness Wow that I
never knew deli meats could be used like
that you can call me anytime
whatever done
what have I done what have I done what
have they done what am I hey hey baby
hey baby are you doing I'm learning new
things about myself
we're all learning new things about
ourselves we're on a journey of
self-discovery which is all that life
really is quickly prolapse love that
name I would like you to know that the
end is nigh [ __ ] me or don't but that
will not stop the endless void from
slowly devouring us this whole planet is
forfeit to the stingy grip of entropy I
like to collect buckets of nails and
just shake them shake them shake them
I don't like stone ale lube throwing up
in ears grit dislikes candy stuffed in
my cushions not your candy bill flipping
the burden namaste you sound like a
delightful chair that I would like to
fornicate upon window shopper I don't
know what that human is all right might
as well oh we're both spinning Oh
oh wow okay so you like a little faster
so each one has their own pace that they
enjoy there we go
okay I'm out the familiarity
I don't know hundred percent what okay
really
this this this is incredible I'm out
still is quite demanding all right now
we're really getting it apparently all
right
oh well the shame is still the same no
matter what happens
haha you brought organ ah mcc's to a
knife fight and still won i what am i
doing the shame of my actions you know
what that one is well that wasn't as
good for me as the old toilet Wow Fanny
ridiculous
Oh Fanny reticulum oh I saw you in many
a WWE match are you the one that got
smashed upon Hulk Hogan remember that
time we watched radio Flyers accompany
and you said no I'm not like you dad so
you put your gun in the fridge to prove
it
I was once king of the Ottoman Empire do
you get it though I don't get it either
this is way too smart for me to
understand or you're Lowell random and I
don't like that likes one dozen eggs
duck colors crown of tongues dislike
square clouds I feel like this was
written by an AI or a chair either way
fancy ridiculous donkey er you're lucky
your name's good I'm gonna blast the
[ __ ] out of you
slower ah Oh e a you sometimes why the
pace is a little difficult to get into
there we go that's the good pace there
we go
I'm out I don't know why I turned
blood-red when I'm out okay what's this
rhythm is very difficult to get there we
go
great this is fantastic
awful you know I don't think it's chair
should be criticizing me then again I
probably shouldn't be [ __ ] a chair in
the first place
oh my god okay
Oh folded you in half how do you feel
about that I don't know what
oh are you dead who died [ __ ] that chair
to death
dan you can seriously [ __ ] a chair
apparently thank you that's what I'm
known for and that's apparently what I
will be known for and only that from
this moment on thank you can you please
forget I ever existed I didn't tell you
my real name fanny radical donk I would
love to keep it up whoa-ho
what a name I hate the implications of
posh [ __ ] machete but what a name I
don't know how to person some say the
world will end in fire and others say
ice I think the world will end with the
screams of a thousand cats realizing
I've come for them aid me in the great
chair ascension like salad ists dislikes
buckets and precious metals are you mate
no you're not made of a precious metal
probably well what do you got against
buckets bookworm I don't know what that
means and I hate what that there you
[ __ ] a book this is is this good for
me is this how slow how slow can I go
listen I just want this over with as
fast as possible and you're asking me to
go slower that only prolongs not that I
have to [ __ ] a chair yeah I guess all
right great oh I nailed the combo right
from the get-go there we go all right
and apparently it's done your gonzo
you're done you're done Yin rings you're
out of here why is there like a train
track running through this why is there
a weird circle around my feet why does
it all line up that way what happened in
this where are we why are we in some
post-apocalyptic parking garage where
are we what am i what is the lore I
appreciate how well you delivered that
bag of hammers to my workshop Oh baby
that's my favorite euphemism yeah I'll
remember you talk about a wide load
socking ttyn pimpled them lift my lid
you don't have a lid number one let's
not lie to each other right off the bat
listen I'm still new to this world but
at least I know respect lifts my lid and
see how excited I am
let's get ourselves a chair [ __ ]
prototype prototype okay likes getting
smelly in the garage editing rush fell
dislikes sex clowns I didn't know sex
clowns were a thing I didn't know chair
[ __ ] was a thing these are two
nightmares that will haunt me for the
rest of my day if I have more than one
day likely it will be the rest of my day
all right
hey whoa hey what's up big chair hey how
you doing I bet you're sturdy Oh faster
okay fat all faster Oh faster oh you
want the speed okay well I bet you want
slow you still want fast okay all right
you can take a beating is what I'm
getting from this I don't know why your
knees buckle like that because I'm so
good at what I do
yeah oh I was right there look I know
what you want apparently and I don't
like that I know what you want I've got
a sixth sense when it comes to [ __ ]
chairs which is probably something that
I should seek therapy about and probably
something that no one will believe much
like seeing ghosts but you know at least
Bruce Willis is looking at me from
around the corner there hiding behind
that pillar Hey Bruce am i doing your
proud also you also [ __ ] chairs
apparently there was no need for that
sound well so I don't think metal should
bend that way nope I think I'm getting
worse
ah look that was a hard to please in
retribution for wasting my time I've
taken your wallet and your keys in your
dignity I
ever had the dignity Oh share Federer
Ling I was hoping my final form would be
a plate treat me like a goat and I'm
putty in your who's like Smosh pitting
with an ostrich dislikes cups of human
organs but bleached so they're a nice
even color but that's a dislike nah Oh
crotch whistle purple that's my new
gamertag oh the new star of YouTube it
was soaked as his crotch whistle ear my
birthday is a bunch of muscle men who
appear out of nowhere and breakdance
shrug I'm pretty sure all my neighbors
are terrified of me now like sky forks
sky fork dislikes screams no no no
screams uses but I want some of that
that sounds delicious programmer fart
magic doink doink doink doink doink
dwoing dwoing dwoing dwoing don't look I
got places to be chair like right here
right now no I got places to go
I got look I'm a busy whatever the
hell'd nightmare creature I am let's
just get it done and then I can go on my
way yes they were you know I mean they
did but if they were gonna make a real
chair [ __ ] simulator because this is
obviously first generation so like I'm
so ready for like the second iteration
you know chair [ __ ] simulator 2 is
really gonna be there but like they you
know it's it's really not feeling
intimate to me it feels like it's just
using chairs I want something that is a
bit more tender you know why not why
can't I plan my life out with the chair
that is the one you know what I mean why
can't I take it my chairs out for a date
you know what I mean why's it gotta all
be about sex I don't get that you know
that's not that's not what I am as an
emotional kind of dude
Jesus Christ oh my god
I see I [ __ ] it to death but I [ __ ]
it too I gotta hide the body oh my god I
think it'll burn a gas oh my god I'm
doomed well I'm in too deep now oh hey
you're such a bad chair [ __ ] noodle
monster you're so hot
I'll bet they boiled you extra long yeah
you know what what saxophone hoop is
tired of your [ __ ] don't talk to me or
my footrest ever again what what I
didn't do I have to call them back
is that wait wait what what what really
so I am juggling these relationships Hey
listen baby hey babe
come on don't be like that you and me we
got something special in this abandoned
building of some kind this post
apocalypse may be detrimental and have
horribly mutated me and you but at the
same time we have something special
something no one else has mostly I don't
know maybe my toes or something I don't
know why my toes are upside-down look
the the radiation really messed me up
but you it only made you more beautiful
why don't you and I why don't we go out
to the radiation River sometime the glow
is so beautiful and it really brings out
the color of your lid oh my god slow the
whole way you are so needy always you
you you what about me
huh what about my needs what about my
chair needs what about what what about
them what about you ever think about
that what about him I'm talking to a
chair that I'm [ __ ] well I mean I'm
not not really I'm very clear it's not
me
[Applause]
BAM listen you're great and all but
you're high maintenance and ain't you
know I'm just not about that I'm a free
spirit you know I can't be tied down to
no chair not one anyway I don't remember
inviting you over to my storage unit but
I'll certainly be doing so in the future
Thanks whatever ambassador what what is
what oh okay well Fanny ridiculous don't
you know what no I did get out of here
Fanny Fanny I think Fanny crotch whistle
you know that's the one you know what
saxophone hoop I'm kind of over you you
you you you done strong sauce pedal Ford
no Bret foot Bret right no I'm gonna be
that's not a chair that's clearly not a
chair
Philip Burt wig sock frown don't you the
fly me you're totally going to the fly
me well the joke's on you buddy
I already vomit all over my doughnuts
when the trash can lid slams down I'm
there likes helmets Phil with cheese
regret clouds pregnant dog dislike socks
awkward hand-holding Seinfeld just
getting warmed up just getting warmed up
was that a skull was that multiple
skulls you have skulls inside of you I
guess it's supposed to pocalypse and
this is the least of my concerns with
the skulls inside of you are a little
odd what is happening I have no idea
what's happening it was some weird
moaning going on the distance I mean
understandably I am [ __ ] a chair but
they're the weird moaning it really
throws me off my game you know I don't
know what's more concerning the fish or
the skulls or the cans or everything or
the [ __ ] you know actually I'm gonna
settle with the [ __ ] that's the most
disturbing thing about all this
oh all right fine sure whatever you are
seriously [ __ ] material you know what
not you though get out of here well Oh
Fanny ridiculous goodbye I don't care go
away
yeah you know what I don't care fanny
ridiculous onk you know I don't care
fishface heart [ __ ] listen I've
forgotten entirely about fanny ridicul
fishface heart [ __ ] is no Josie John Joe
Bob Joe big I was once a man see this is
the lure that I was talking about
these aren't chairs they're people this
toilet was once a man something changed
me into a tube and something changed you
into a turlet fish bump peepee well
there boy oh man lather up my lack
towards you put it into the oven
pockets no no no no no roses are red
clowns clowns clowns gear pusher come on
my Skeletor likes kneecaps dislikes
semen in a can pregnant Batman
this is randomly generated alright sure
whatever you know what I've lost all my
dignity so at this point no no no is
this one of those sex clowns I heard so
much about Oh No Quality Assurance I
don't know what who is that what do
someone there wait what there was
someone there what the hell you're still
there oh my god it's not gonna show me
oh my god okay will
huh look at that there's someone there
that's the most terrifying that why are
you go away who are you who are you have
you always been there have I just never
noticed I hate this squeaking and you're
dead you know this one actually I don't
regret as much because honestly I want
to hide the evidence that this ever
happened and if that guy behind the
pillar was filming me that's gonna be a
problem not that I think that there's a
society left to understand this or that
I have any sort of public recognition
given that I'm a giant tube I just don't
know who you are I am stuck in a room
surrounded by angel statues great stay
there does this game actually have a
secret like horrible lore to it what is
it share a miserable pile of secrets a
demon summoning monster what do you
think of chair frog screaming Lex farty
buds dislikes pink salads I don't want
to know what a pink salad is a troubling
hobby hey I hate that face the guy's not
there anymore there's something going on
here and I don't like it slow slow slow
slow slow slow
listen try and reel but I'm so tired you
know seeing a lot of chairs
recently boink ooh what's with the
fireworks I mean what's with the chair
[ __ ] but also what's with the
fireworks in the Ring of Fire
it's all symbolic it's all symbolic it's
all symbolism that really did it time to
go buy some wood glue you're not made of
wood go away the chest wound God bro I
got what plants crave right here look
look at it key Jen music plays well my
PC lights on fire and shoots urine at me
from the CD Drive sure at least you're a
different chair slightly creeper aah
creeper why is there someone here I hate
that achievement I hate what that
suggests first I was like aah Julie game
now I'm just
it's very uncomfortable because if
people were actually knowing that I did
this I would be probably very
detrimental to my personal well-being oh
that's what you get whatever chest wound
chest wound
oh yes my my yes thank you oh thank you
so much I've never experienced that much
wet noodle before and it was absolutely
divine thanks bye
crotch whistle oh no fine okay whatever
who cares oh there it is again
I got 200% that's nice I don't like that
I'm getting better at chair [ __ ]
simulator that seems like something
that's not what I want on my resume
BAM another one fights that no leg to
stand on I don't know what that means
that might be my best ever I got an A in
chair [ __ ] class thanks teacher I
haven't felt this alive since the great
chair wars you know I bet there were
great chair wars and apparently the
chairs won I can't believe how
desensitized I've become to share
[ __ ] oh oh I've never failed before
oops
Yee I didn't blast him away but I guess
it doesn't matter us clowns be [ __ ] I
don't think you're what you think you
are what happens if I just screw up
you'll like that you like that you like
that you like and I'm bothered donk
that's what you get it's all you guys so
I got I'm tired you know doing this all
day one one percent yeah you know what
where's my coffee you know what you
don't deserve it eager face what does
the eager face then an entire counter
mostly twerking yep
0% baby
when I go ahead and what the authorities
know where you live yep that's probably
for the best
swipe left to avoid a terrible fate what
does it even mean and five encounters
badly yep it's not you know wait it is
what was it and Tenten can't any
encounters badly yeah you know it's how
I do all right you know what I'm done
this has been chair [ __ ] simulator I
spent way too much time [ __ ] chairs I
don't think there's a secret to be had
and I feel stupid for being drawn into
the idea that there was a secret to be
had this game is for a very specific
type of person of whom I am NOT so thank
you everybody so much for watching if
for some reason you want to play this
game and you want to discover the dark
secret lurking in the center of the
chair links will be in the description
I'm gonna throw this game into the
playlist with all the other weird
strange uncatted erisa below video z'
that i've played in the past of which
there are many games which just can't be
explained in simple terms actually no
this one can be explained in simple
terms it's a chair [ __ ] simulator you
simulate [ __ ] Church alright cool I'm
out of here thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I'll see you
in the next video bye bye
[Music]